so over the course of the day you've
seen a lot of technologies presented and
ways in which you can optimize for
operators and developers and things like
that what we want to do in this session
is show you something you could build
and to end with these technologies and
how you would use them kind of give you
the use case for how these might be
stitched together so my name is Vic
Iglesias
I'm cloud solutions architect the other
two are Amir and Steve and they are the
brave folks who are gonna do the live
demo portion of what I'll be explaining
so I get the easy part here and they're
the real heroes so I'll first talk about
why you should build a platform then
we'll talk about the platform that we're
demoing today and and what that looks
like
Amir will will demo the onboarding of an
application to the platform and then
Steve will talk about how we roll out to
production so why should you build up
platform we'll start this conversation
by talking about what is a platform and
really it's it's this idea of an
abstraction between your developers and
operators it's like the simplest way I
could put it you want your developers to
have one single way that they know how
to iterate on their services and they're
really good at it but also as operators
you want to be able to iterate on the
underlying infrastructure you don't want
to be stuck on whatever decision you
made five years ago for infrastructure
you want to be able to iterate on those
pieces while maintaining your developers
productivity that's a huge huge task so
what we do is we build platforms we
build these abstractions that allow
developers to do their things and stay
consistent you might have you know and a
hundred times more developers than you
do operators you want to make sure that
those folks are able to iterate and how
many folks in here actually like their
company ship software and then makes
money from it yeah a lot of us right you
you have to do that how many folks have
to have software to run your business
the rest of them right we need to
maintain the developer productivity and
keep high reliability as we work through
these challenges when you look under the
covers things get pretty complicated a
lot of the time right you started in
your data center things were fine you
maybe had just dev and prod people were
just Isis aging to machines and throwing
jars everywhere for the very beginning
that got a little cagey so you added a
staging logical environment so you could
test out your changes and from there you
added a cloud provider maybe it was GCP
who knows
and you you started to complicate things
now having two physical locations where
things are located also having those
many logical environments so things get
complex under the hood for these
operators and we want to make that
easier some of the complications you end
up with here are inconsistent ways that
people deploy or think about CI or run
their builds and all of that stuff means
that you're not sharing your best
practices with each other all of the
innovation that you're seeing in one
part of your company is not being
leveraged in in the others right another
thing that you start to see is that
those logical environments don't
actually mean what you thought they
meant you thought you had a staging
environment that was staged to be like
production but the end of the day it's
so far from it that you're not even
learning things that would hit
production and you're seeing your bugs
hit prod anyway obviously you can't test
for everything but that's that's the
goal of having those logical
environments the next thing is you start
up start figuring out that it's hard to
even get people the right access to the
right things to be able to get their job
done now you want a standard way to do
those kinds of things including
configuring which apps can connect to
each other dan showed a great demo of a
steal and service mesh and things that
we can actually use to connect services
in the secure and reliable way the last
one is mostly for operators here where
each team does ops differently and so
when an outage hits you have to figure
out what their best practices for
logging and monitoring and all that
stuff are and where their systems are
and how they do their actual logs and
whether they're JSON or not you start to
see a lot of this stuff when you're not
building platforms to operate for
developers and operators to have an
abstraction so then you say we've had
platforms right we've had things like
App Engine things like Cloud Foundry
hosted platforms platforms of the
service in 2008 Google launched App
Engine right and this helped a lot of
companies not think about all the
operational aspects they just got scale
to millions of requests per second for
free with just a little bit of code
turns out this seemed very opinionated
too enterprises it was too hard for them
to make a leap into the platform as a
service world so we started to see
platforms like infrastructure as a
service like coop compute engine in 2012
which was launched which gave you the
most flexibility just run a VM and put
software on it it's gonna be
easy turns out that was kind of hard as
well in 2015 we launched kubernetes
engine and that was kind of a happy
medium for folks it was like enough of
an infrastructure abstraction it turns
out it can run kind of anywhere now and
this is a new building block that folks
are building they're kind of bespoke
platforms on top of and what you get
here is a nice infrastructure
abstraction and then the ability to add
all the pieces that you need in between
them there may be some bespoke choices
in your company like you chose a
particular cloud provider identity
provider or a secrets management tool
that you need to integrate and
kubernetes gets you it gives you a lot
of flexibility to make those choices how
many folks know this gentleman
Kelsey Hightower he's awesome we prayed
to him for Amir and Steve's sake that
the demo goes well Kelsey said that
kubernetes is a platform for building
platforms it's not your end game it's a
better place to start and that's kind of
what we're gonna do throughout this talk
to the demo so how do you build a
platform on anthos first thing to look
at is what are the layers of your stack
when you're when you're talking about
applications you have infrastructure
layers which is your networking your
compute storage things like that and
those provides a way to abstract that
away and so above that you create kind
of platform tools or sets of tools that
make up your platform you might have a
source code management system a CI
system and a continuous delivery system
that you build on top in order to give
your developers that you know get commit
to do the right thing experience so why
would you build on top of anthos you get
a central essentially manager
infrastructure we had anthos config
management as an example of that you get
a single API that you know you can use
to deploy workloads you have an
interface which is like the docker image
and then you know from there you can go
to any of your ear locations or
environments and deploy and it allows
you to then share those methodologies
across your teams or centralize those
methodologies and then extend them and
as I said previously you can run
kubernetes and gke now anywhere right
whether it be on pram or in the cloud so
as we're building out platforms we're
thinking about three main personas the
developers the security and policy folks
who are
trying to figure out what can't to be
done in the platform and our operators
who are just trying to keep the lights
on and make sure that things are running
smoothly in order to build a platform we
think you need to have one of each of
these components I talked about a lot of
these Dan talked about Apple deserve
ability which we can introduce with a
steel and Antho service mesh we need a
way to manage our source code a way to
manage our configuration C ICD
methodologies a way to manage our policy
and then ways to run our containers so
in this talk in the demo we'll we'll go
through what it's like to build this out
choosing one of each of these components
and then stitching it all together and
showing it to folks as we've gone
through this we've seen that there's
really three interfaces that these
components use to talk to each other we
have git repositories so we can push and
pull code source code sometimes that's a
kubernetes manifest we can push and pull
docker images from a repository that's
our heart our deployable artifact and
then we configure that deployable
artifact using kubernetes manifests that
we deploy to clusters the ant the way
that we're using ant those can
configuration management in this example
is by using it to sync policy and
structure of namespaces across our
clusters so we store all of that
configuration in the centralized git
repo and then it gets applied to all of
our clusters and what we end up with in
each of these namespaces that we create
for our applications is one service
account that that application uses to
deploy within that cluster it has a CI
runner so that's in our case we're using
git lab so we have a git lab CI runner
running in that namespace just for that
application and then that deploys with
that service count all the the resources
that the application requires whether
that's deployments or services or in
grasses or anything like that and then
these are all replicated across each of
our clusters so as we add a cluster to
an environment it gets the same exact
setup as the other clusters that's in
there it's a nice way to centralize that
the other thing we're gonna be doing is
deployment with git ops so this has been
an idea that's been around for a while
and now has a name to it the get-ups
methodology and what that means is we're
gonna have our application configuration
living inside of an app repo and we're
gonna have our kubernetes config in
there and then we're gonna hydrate that
manifest we're gonna render that
fest into a fully-fledged kubernetes
manifest that can be applied into a
cluster but before doing that we're
going to commit it to a git repository
and that gives us a way to track what
was what was deployed and when and what
the diffs were between those those
commits so in this example we're gonna
have that environment repo have two
branches one staging branch which maps
to what's in the staging clusters and
then one master branch which maps to
what's in production as far as managing
our configuration or application
configuration we're gonna be using
customize which is a way to manage your
kubernetes manifest rather than
templating them you're gonna be able to
create a base set of manifests and then
apply patches to them for various use
cases
another thing that customized can do is
apply labels and annotations across a
set of resources and/or add a prefix so
a lot of a big use case for adding a
prefix is I want to prefix everything
with the environment name so you have a
base that just says what your resources
are and then in customize you can apply
prod dash or staging dash to all the
resources so when you see them in your
your dashboards and in your kubernetes
CLI you can tell which environment
you're in really easily without having
to go into each of those resources and
change it yourself and one of the key
method ologies that Customize uses is to
have these patches on top of a base the
other place that we see this is in
docker images right you have in docker
from Ubuntu 1604 or 1804 that's the base
image then you run commands on top of
that and make little tweaks to the file
system we have a very similar approach
with customize so you have a set of base
manifests and then from there you add
overlays or patches on top of that that
sprinkle in the changes that you want
without changing that original base that
base might be used for a completely
different use case in another place and
you just do what you need in order to
transform that for yours one concrete
way you can see this is I have a base
set of you know kubernetes manifests
that I call my application and then for
each of my environments I have
application environment specific patches
that I applied to each of those before I
finally hydrate those and so
them into my clusters that's a very
basic use case for customized so now on
the demo we'll talk through a little bit
of the cloud architecture the will have
five clusters in this demo we'll have
one for dev that is where they can
iterate they have some namespaces that
they're locked into on in that cluster
they iterate with something like
scaffold or cloud run on their own and
then they commit some code oops
we need the slides back and power up
here it looks like so yet you have a
tools cluster in there we have our CI CD
tools all those platform pieces that I
talked about in that layered
infrastructure diagram are gonna be in a
tools cluster we're using git lab for
this and so the developers are gonna
commit and merge in git lab and then
that's going to make its way to staging
and then finally to production clusters
here we have one staging cluster in two
production clusters and I'll talk a
little bit about how the code repos work
again we're gonna have two main repos
the code repo and the environment repo
when a developer commits to a feature
branch they're iterating on their local
environment then eventually they're
gonna make a merge request to the master
branch of the CIA PO then from there
that's automatically going to be
committed to the staging repo of the
staging branch of the environment repo
and and added to the staging environment
so now everything that's in master of
the developers repo is ready to go in
staging now if we want to get a change
from staging to production we merge in
the environment repo from staging to
master and that does a CI run or a CD
run that pushes directly in to the
production clusters so with that we'll
take it over to Amir who will take us
through it sounds good
can you guys hear me all right everybody
clear on what Vic just said we need to
run this demo we're running on like
seven percent we're running on like six
percent battery life so I'm gonna go
pretty fast alright so yeah we just
found out that it's not charging so my
name is Amir I'm also an SA Solutions
Architect err Google and I will be your
operator for the rest of the ten minutes
or so that we have let's all put on our
operators hats and let's assume that our
developer just walked up to us and said
hey I have this new go app I'd like to
deploy hi miles how are you awesome
and then so what do we do so like any
other platform-as-a-service we'd start
with the CLI which is what you see up
here we have this handy-dandy CLI tool
that we are going to use to add a new
application called hello cube con 1 into
our CIT d platform maybe alright let me
just make sure I'm in the right folder
huh check out so good one more all right
CLI is a good way of adding an
application it's nice and consistent
everybody gets to do it the same way you
don't make any kind of human mistakes
but in this particular case we're using
Antos platform CLI the name of our
application is just going to be hello
cube con 2019 we give it our CIC DS host
name which in this case is get lab the
password and then the the template right
so again template gives you kind of that
boilerplate code kind of already made up
right so what's happening in the
background I'll just quickly explain is
in get lab it's creating a group and a
group is nothing more than just a
collection of repositories just like an
organization and github and in this case
it's creating those two repositories one
is your application code repositories
that's what you hand off to your
developers that's where they iterate on
their applications and then the other
one is your operators repository or your
environment repositories that's where
all of the kubernetes resource manifests
reside for all all environments so for
dev stage and prod keeping those two
separate kind of keeps the CI of the
developer separated from the CD of the
operator it's a nice way to do that
another thing that Vic mentioned is that
every application gets deployed in its
own namespace on every single cluster
and as part of that namespace a git lab
Runner which is just a deployment is
deployed inside of that namespace now
there's a couple of schools of thought
here one is how do we push these
manifests down to the clusters so
there's two ways to do that we can
either give kind of the credentials to
the git repos and every single get
rebuilt for every single kubernetes
cluster and we push those configs down
so the credentials kind of remain
outside of it or in this case we are
giving those credentials as a service
account to the git lab runner and then
giving the get lab runner the get
credential so it can pull those
manifests in order to do that we have to
give this get lab runner access to pull
those images right so I'm going to click
on this link
I'm just gonna create some credentials
so this is very similar to just creating
a docker login and in this case the only
thing it really needs is read access to
the registry so it can pull the images
so I'll create a user called get reader
it doesn't matter what we call it we'll
give it read registry access I'll create
the deploy token and will give me this
username and password we'll copy this
password go back to our command line
give it the username which is get reader
copy the password and let it kind of
finish the bootstrap so let's take a
look at what it actually got created in
gitlab so I'm gonna go into get lab go
to groups and go to your groups so we
can see all of them so the first thing
you notice is that we have this new
group created called hello cube con 2019
we go into that group we have the two
repositories the bottom one is your
application repository that's the one
for your developers the top one is your
end or your environment repository
that's the one for your resource
manifests for kubernetes will inspect
those here shortly I'm gonna go back
into the groups and I'm gonna look at
this group called platform admins and
this is an operators group there's quite
a few repositories kind of in here right
so I'll highlight a few of them the
first one are these templated
repositories so the golang template and
the golang template ends again like I
said it kind of gives our developers a
boilerplate of a starting point of
something they can code so you don't
have to do this every single time so you
can have other templates for Java Ruby
go and what what have you we heard about
Antos config management this morning and
this is the platform that sets up kind
of the foundation the namespaces the
registries and stuff like that inside of
this repository this is by the way what
the folder structure looks like there's
a namespace folder so we're going to the
namespaces folder and the managed apps
folder you can see that we now have as
part of that bootstrap that we did with
the CLI command we have a hello cube con
2019 folder we'll go into that folder
and you'll notice that like I said it
creates the namespace for that
application it creates that registry
secret that's that docker login that we
just created and it feeds that to all of
the gitlab runners in each namespace for
each cluster so you see that three
runners two for the production clusters
fraud central prod East and the staging
so now each cluster has pulled
missions to pull register to pull images
from that registry and if we want to
look at what that looks like inside of
the cluster so again I'm in the cloud
console we're looking at the kubernetes
engine workloads page and I've already
put a filter for that namespace on there
and if we hit refresh you'll notice that
we have the three gitlab runners we also
have something else deployed and we'll
talk about that shortly but I really
want you to focus on the three runners
that are scoped to that namespace so
they're running within that hello queue
con 2019 namespace in each of the
clusters the to production clusters and
the one staging cluster and those their
permissions are scoped within that
namespace they can't put anything
outside of that so let's go back to our
platform admins group another thing I
wanted to show you was the shared CI CD
repository so this is where all of the
CI CD for every single language will sit
here so in the CI folder for example
you'll have all of the manifests for a
different CI file so we have one for go
here as an example and you can see it's
fairly simple it's doing a unit test
which just go get go test and then just
a build stage right again this could be
as as deep as you'd like it to be and
then the last thing I want to mention
here our customized basis these are the
shared customized basis like Vic talked
about for every language we have a
folder so we can go into the golang
folder and in this demo we're just doing
a deployment and a service but you can
have other kubernetes manifests and they
don't look scary at all they look just
like a vanilla kubernetes deployment and
things like we can change our
environment so which environment they're
going into dev stage or prod we can
change the image name because majority
of the time you're not changing the
entire yamo you're just changing a few
things and that's where that patch kind
of comes in and to show you that now
let's go ahead and inspect our actual
application group so I'm going to go
back into hello coupon 2019 group and
we're gonna start with the application
repo so again this is the boilerplate
this is the repository that gets handed
over to the developers and you can see
the first thing we just gave them some
boilerplate code this is just a simple
hello world app that the developers can
start iterating upon in the same
repositories we have the darker files
this is what builds the artifacts we
have scaffolds so they can start doing
some developments and local dev testing
before they even push this to this to
this particular repo we have this get
lab see
which is their CIC D file for this
particular repo this pipeline gets
kicked off anytime somebody commits
makes a commit to the master branch of
this application repo and I already
showed you the test and build and
Steve's gonna show you kind of how the
deployment piece works what's
interesting about this is in as part of
the application repo we also have the
kubernetes manifest so the developer is
not only get to see what actually gets
deployed they also have influence over
how it does it right so inside of that
Kate's folder we have the three folders
for the three environments so for
example if we go to the staging folder
first thing is that it's pulling that
shared customized basis from that repo
that I showed you earlier
so as an operator I can go and make a
change to that shared base one time if
let's say I want to change the logging
level or if I want to add resource
limits or something I'll just change it
one time and in the next rollout this
will get applied across the board and
then here's the patch the deployment
patch that is being applied for this
particular thing if we just look at that
very very quickly all we're doing here
is giving it the environment variable
and then giving it the the name of the
image which Steve will show you shortly
so as a developer I can actually go in
and I can change this patch to let's say
if I want more CP or something or if I
want to change the image if I want to
push a different image to staging I can
do that here so I still have that
control over staging so now I mentioned
that every time a commit is made to the
master branch a pipeline is kicked off
so here on the left-hand side I'm going
to go to CI CD pipelines and you can see
that one pipeline because of the initial
bootstrapping was kicked off and let's
click on that pipeline and it's just a
simple four stage CI CD step again this
could be as complex as you'd like the
first two are pretty self-explanatory
and I already kind of showed you those
this is the unit test that happened and
then the building of that image once
that image is built in the registry
somehow we need to deploy that and for
that I'm gonna hand it off to Steve and
he's gonna talk more about how that gets
deployed yeah all right cool I'm Steve
McGee I'm a former essary so I get the
honor slash duty of pushing this thing
into production so great okay so the
first thing we're gonna do is a it's
still part of the CI step
it's kind of the beginning of CD which
is hydrating these manifest so these are
these Yamla files that we talked about
before so before we had like the base
image and the patches and you kind of
think about variables and templates this
is all of it expanded out so we have two
files one's gonna be customized staging
the other ones customized krod and that
way if we have any trouble down the line
we know exactly what got pushed to
production the first step is just to
build those and we can click through
here and we can show you builds them all
it's very simple it builds one right
here it runs a customized come in for
customized staging and then it does it
again for production so after that we
have these two files what do we do with
them we just push them over to another
repo right so now we're moving from the
code repo to the environment repo I
won't really show you this because it's
just like copy it's not very interesting
so let's back out into the group and
we're gonna show you the end repo the
environment repo and we'll show you
where those files kind of end up so I go
here oh my gosh where are the files well
we forgot we actually pushed it to a
branch right we pushed it to the staging
branch so as soon as we move over there
here we go we've got our two files so we
can look at one let's look at staging
and it shouldn't be scary in any way
it's pretty basic right so we have our
environment label staging just like we
expect it has the name hello cube con so
all those things that look tall vanilla
before have all been filled in with the
right stuff okay so we saw before that
there were three runners running in
kubernetes and there was also a job
running there was the actual staging app
right so this is this guy right here it
already got out there how did that how
the heck did that happen and the reason
why that happened is because when we
made the the first commit we pushed this
file all the way to the environment
branch into the staging branch and our
friend the pipeline ran again so let's
see this new pipeline that ran this is a
different pipeline this one you just did
one thing it deployed to staging so we
can click in here we can see there's
this job that ran this this this binary
that runs we're using something called
gke deploy and it's think of it just as
like cube control apply except it does a
couple other little fancy things and it
waits for it to succeed and then once it
does it sort of tells you here go look
at your job it's running it's great so
we can see yes indeed it's running so at
this point the develop says great my job
is what I expected the
is doing the featuring let's push it to
prod and then yes or he shows up goes
like you got it let's do it you know the
schedule is correct we're ready to go
and then if you recall from the kind of
interesting flow chart the way we do
this is we're going to do it by
promoting the the environment yamo from
the staging branch to the master branch
we do that and get lab using what's
called a merge request which you
probably already know we're gonna make a
new merge request we're gonna give it a
very very descriptive name like go
oh no the computer stops computering
okay rod okay so we're gonna go to prod
so we want to make sure we're actually
going from staging to master that looks
pretty good we're gonna submit a merge
request some other person might come in
like you might want to have another set
of eyes go yeah this looks fine they
might come in and say well let's take a
look at the changes make sure they're
exactly what we expect you might also
have other things in your pipeline like
to make sure that we have you know the
right amount of resources in place etc
this is really boring because it's just
like a blank entry let's say it looks
good we're gonna merge it let's go so
now what happens in this process yet
another pipeline happens of course it
does that's how this works
in this case there's one step for each
cluster so for each production cluster
it's exactly the same as the staging one
except this time it's pushing to
production so we have two clusters here
one is just in central one look it
already finished and the next one's
gonna be an east one you might have
another step in here that's like weight
or you know check the canary or you know
something something but we just did
something very simple so let's take a
look at your pennies and make sure it's
working it should be ready oh it's
working so we have one running in
central one and then the US east one is
coming up as well so let's take a look
at the logs viewer and we're gonna see
if it is really running so for each
cluster we should be able to see the
health checks come by and ideally what
we're gonna see is three sets of apps
all running kind of you know skewed from
each other stream stream this is it guys
this is gonna be it
this is this is where we pray - Kelsey
yeah so we have health checks in staging
we have it in prod we have in prod
central and eventually we will have ones
from fraud East as well but that's it
you know our code is deployed it's in
many places another thing to point out
fraud East and fraud central could be
two different types of kubernetes on two
different platforms you know this is
this is the amazing thing about anthos
it doesn't care it's just kubernetes so
that's it all right if we could go back
to slides for a little bit that was
pretty good I I will continue to bring
them along for future and those days I
don't want to do the demos all right so
let's take a quick review we saw a lot
of things a lot of terms flew around
code and arrows and all kinds of stuff
so we had developers committing to an
application repo that was kicking off CI
and then that built an artifact our
doctor image and stored it in our
container registry from there it was
added to our application configuration
the operators were able to get their
base configuration and put that into the
application configuration with that
image and then that was committed to our
environment repo where the CD process
was started the other thing that we saw
is that policy and security engineers
were able to create that landing zone
for our applications and those
namespaces with the right policies in a
git repo as well and have those
propagate to all our clusters so that's
kind of the the shape of what a platform
might look like if it's built on top of
anthos the last thing I want to just
review is a lot about how we propagated
our best practices as operators through
this platform with the ability to use
git Labs includes we can have a
centralized repo where we're having most
of our CI steps that has a library that
developers can pick from so they have a
good starting point and then can iterate
from there we also can do the same thing
for our continuous delivery processes
and with our application config we have
our shared customized basis which we can
store and get and then reference from
our application repos and so we're
pulling in our best practices and then
as we iterate on those as operators
those automatically propagate on the
next run to our developers also we have
the ability to store our
our environment configuration in a
repository and have that reviewed by sre
and security and whoever else before any
changes are merged into production so
with that I'd ask you to please come
talk to us at either the Google cloud
booth or here I think we have a break
coming up right now and ask about the
anthos platform demo thank you folks so
much
[Applause]
you